adding the true story tagline
is a common way to entice moviegoers to
the box office but
as we all know hollywood has a habit of
sensationalizing things and
twisting the truth in order to keep
audiences captivated it's time to look
past the silver screen and see why being
based on a true story isn't all it's
cracked up to be
fargo the movie starts with the text
that says this
is a true story the movie fargo adds
that the events of the film happened in
minnesota in 1987
so then why do the movies closing
credits feature the
all persons fictitious disclaimer the
coen brothers
loosely based the script on actual
events and formulated the events before
and after it in 2016 20 years
after the movie's 1996 debut the
brothers
finally revealed their inspirations in
an interview with the huffington
post said joel there are actually two
little elements in the story that were
based on
actual incidents one of them is the fact
that there was a guy i believe in the
60s or 70s
who was gumming up serial numbers for
cars and defrauding the general motors
finance corporation
there was no kidnapping there was no
murder it was a guide to frauding the gm
finance corporation
at some point the other thing that's
based on something real
there was a murder in connecticut where
a man killed his wife and disposed of
the body
put her in a wood chipper but beyond
that the story's made up
rudy a sports classic rudy is inspiring
uplifting and fast and loose with the
truth
remember that scene where the players
placed their jerseys on coach devine's
desk to convince him
to let rudy play and the crowd started
chanting his name
that never happened and joe montana who
was
on the team with rudy confirmed to
sports illustrated that
it's a movie remember not all that's
true
the crowd wasn't chanting nobody threw
in their jerseys
he did get in the game and he got
carried off the game
argo ben affleck won three academy
awards including best picture for argo
but it's pretty inaccurate especially
the way it minimizes canada's role in
the whole
hostage extraction plan none other than
president jimmy carter himself called
out argo for making stuff up
my judgment is that ninety percent of
the credit
for that heroic and brilliant move
should have been with the canadians and
the
movie ignores practically
any contribution by the canadians fox
catcher
depicting john du pont's murder of
olympic wrestler dave schultz
plenty of what appears on screen in
foxcatcher
is accurate but the filmmakers took lots
of liberties with the timeline and
characters relationships
for instance foxcatcher shows dupont's
quick apprehension by the police
in reality the millionaire hid it in his
mansion's secure room
in a multi-day standoff the movie also
doesn't really show how much time passes
between dave schultz joining team
foxcatcher
which happened in 1989 and his death
around 1996
dupont started losing interest in the
sport as he announced he was ending his
400 000
annual contributions to the team which
wasn't featured in the film
months before the murder american sniper
critics have pointed out differences
between the life of chris kyle the navy
seal with the most confirmed kills
in united states military history and
the character that's based on him
betrayed by bradley cooper in american
sniper
one of the many distortions comes in the
form of mustafa
the enemy sniper kyle battles mustafa
only shows up in kyle's memoirs for one
paragraph
whereas the movie portrays him as a long
time antagonist
in the book kyle's super long range shot
of over 2 000 yards
wasn't fired on mustafa but on someone
carrying a rocket launcher
the blind side in 2009 audiences saw
how michael ohr was adopted by a wealthy
family and overcame the odds to become
an
nfl star in the blind side it also
inspired
all to write a book to set the record
straight for starters
orr said that lee ann tui played by
sandra bullock in the movie
didn't teach him how to play football or
wrote
i felt like it betrayed me as dumb
quinton aaron did a great job acting the
part but
i could not figure out why the director
chose to show me
as someone who had to be taught the game
of football
rush the formula one flick rush
generated some great reviews
but it's full of historical
exaggerations one of the biggest
distortions is the fact that james hunt
and nicki louder played by chris
hemsworth and daniel brawl
are portrayed as bitter rivals they were
actually
good friends having once been roommates
and drinking buddies
also a few of the film's racing events
were changed as to how they turned out
and
who participated and james hunt has also
never
punched a journalist
[Music]
captain phillips based on the true story
of the 2009 maersk alabama hijacking by
somali pirates captain phillips shows
audiences
how the guy with his name in the title
saved the lives of his crew
but an anonymous crew member from the
actual ship
leveled accusations that the real
phillips isn't much of a hero at all
according to his claims phillips
practically invited the hijacking by
ignoring safety protocols and sailing
too close to the coast
phillips supposedly had multiple email
warnings about increasing
piracy around somalia the crew also
claims that they endured two pirate
attacks on that trip
and not just one a beautiful mind
this russell crowe classic was an
inspiring look into the life story of
economics nobel laureate john nash
sort of nash never actually joined
wheeler laboratory at mit
because it doesn't exist and while the
real nash did become
an instructor at mit he never worked for
the department of defense
the movie also shows him as a dad and he
did become a father in real life
of a child out of wedlock and he
abandoned the mother
nash also never actually gave an
acceptance speech of his nobel prize
still it's not a bad way to end a movie
the most important discovery of my life
[Music]
it is only in the mysterious equations
of love
that any logical reasons can be found
that's the stuff that oscar dreams
are made of god bless and thank you for
the support
thanks for watching subscribe to our
youtube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
which movie you can't believe
isn't the whole truth